[Musica]
la letteratura è una delle discipline
che forniscono concetti e racconti per
la descrizione nel nostro tempo non
prova nemmeno a darvi un quadro
sintetico di ciò che la letteratura
intesa come intero dice sul nostro tempo
inteso come intero perché tutto questo
sarebbe impossibile in un quarto d'ora
mi concentro su un caso però un caso
fondamentale litigando col powerpoint
ecco per paolo pasolini per paolo
pasolini poeta critico letterario
romanziere regista in questo momento
viene discusso soprattutto perché autore
di articoli di giornale usciti
all'inizio degli anni settanta e
raccolti in quel libro intitolato
scritti corsari che avete indicato nel
power point articoli di giornale in cui
si parla di società e di politica si
parla in particolare delle
trasformazioni modo di vedere
pasoliniano straordinaria che le sulla
società italiana in particolare le
società occidentali in generale
avrebbero subito tra la seconda metà
degli anni 50 e gli anni 60 attraverso
quei passaggi che in italia sono
scanditi da ciò che chiamiamo il
miracolo economico e dal 1968 pasolini
conia per descrivere questo passaggio un
concetto che ha avuto molta fortuna e dà
molta fortuna facendo parte del
dibattito politico e sociologico un
contemporaneo e ogni tanto ricomparendo
ciclicamente nei giornali il concetto di
mutazione antropologica
secondo pasolini l'italia e l'occidente
sarebbero passati da una società arcaica
dominante contadina piccolo borghese una
società repressiva una società che
controllava i comportamenti una società
che inibiva
la libertà sessuale una società fondata
sulle idee di dovere di sacrificio e
sulla religione ad una società laica
incentrata sul piacere fondata sulla
liberazione sessuale sui consumi e sullo
spettacolo uno dei saggi fondamentali
raccolti in scritti corsari a aveva come
oggetto una campagna pubblicitaria
dell'inizio degli anni 70 quando i jeans
jesus lanciarono la loro nuova linea di
prodotti e chiesero a oliviero toscani
di curare la campagna pubblicitaria
oliviero toscani riempì le città
italiane di enormi cartelloni che fatti
più o meno in questo modo c'erano
diversi puzzle in e commenta 2 questo è
uno dei due cartelloni commentati da
pasolini un sedere femminile uno degli
shorts e una citazione da gesù chi mi
ama mi segua
pasolini che aveva visto essendo nato
nel 1922 l'italia cattolica vera
profonda eccetera
quando all'inizio degli anni settanta si
trova davanti questo slogan disposto
nella maniera che vedete capisce che di
essere davanti ad una trasformazione
epocale e questo articolo è uno dei
pezzi che aprono gli scritti corsari e
nei quali l'idea di mutazione
antropologica si definisce mutazione
antropologica poi entrato nel nella
discussione corrente ed è oggi una delle
nozioni pasoliniane più dibattute se non
la più dibattuta è una nozione
illuminante è una nozione controversa
pasolini è stato ampiamente criticato è
stato ampiamente criticato usando molti
argomenti
ne cito due il primo è che nella visione
del passaggio da una italia arcaica
contadina e super e gotica religiosa ad
un'italia edonistica liberata
consumistica che non riconosce più
alcuno spazio e sacralità ci sarebbero
uno dei tratti nostalgici e dei tratti
che qualcuno qualifica come reazionari
non è un'idea sbagliata in nei testi
pasolini ali aleggia una sorta di
nostalgia per quell'italia non per nella
sua versione diciamo borghese ma nella
sua versione popolare in realtà pasolini
odia entrambe le italia o di alitalia
che chiama clerico fascista cioè quella
della prima metà del novecento ma odia
anche l'italia del consumo dello
spettacolo che considera regressiva che
considera omologante che considera
strutturata intorno ad una forma di
rimbecillimento collettivo inaccettabile
e politicamente reazionario
dunque ci sono toni nostalgici in
pasolini
un'altra critica molto interessante
forse più interessante della prima è che
il concetto di mutazione antropologica
non va applicato soltanto a quello
spezzone del novecento la modernità
tutta intera è una lunga continua
mutazione antropologica gli ultimi due
secoli e mezzo sono stati nella storia
della cultura europea e occidentale in
generale
sto un sono stati dei secoli di
straordinaria vertiginosa accelerazione
il testo che per primo e più chiaramente
fissa questa accelerazione questo
processo è il manifesto del partito
comunista di marx engels in un passo del
manifesto del partito comunista si legge
la modernità è quell epoca in cui tutto
ciò che è solido si dissolve nell'aria e
ogni cosa viene profanata l'origine
della mutazione antropologica se volete
molto lontana pasolini né descrivere
l'ultimo tratto ma le forze in campo di
cui pasolini rifà alla storia sono
antiche che cosa rimane oggi di questo
concetto guida come l'idea di mutazione
antropologica può essere oggi riusata o
abbandonati
è molto interessante che negli stessi
anni in cui pasolini scrive agli
articoli confluiti in scritti corsari e
agisce con la sua sensibilità di
scrittore il forse più importante
psicoanalista del secondo novecento
jacques lacan scrive degli articoli
analoghi o meglio non scrivere gli
articoli analoghi piene delle conferenze
che poi verranno sbobinate e pubblicate
in versione scritta ha scritto
direttamente molto poco gran parte la
sua opera nasce da trascrizioni
negli stessi anni e in seguito agli
stessi sommovimenti cioè l'equivalente
francese del miracolo economico e il 68
la canon riflette su quello che sta
succedendo sulle trasformazioni
straordinari che stanno avendo luogo nel
mondo cui assiste ed elabora due
concetti la nuova società che si va
preparando e che si sta formando dice la
coop è fondata su quella che lui chiama
l'obbligo di godere il piacere è
diventato individuale è diventato il
primo dei valori è diventato una sorta
di obbligo se volete c'è una contrattura
una versione paradossale un conflitto
paradossale tra obbligo e piacere in
questo questo conflitto paradossale si
fonda però il nuovo assetto del presente
che la cerca di descrivere un altra
nozione che la associa a quella del
dell'obbligo di godere è quella
dell'evaporazione della legge
l'evaporazione dei legami e
l'evaporazione di quello che lui chiama
il padre che se l'istanza simbolica
della legge
si va verso una società in cui i legami
sono sempre più allentati sono sempre
meno importanti ciò che rimane è
l'individuo spesso lacerato al suo
interno e la sua volontà di godere come
vedete fra pasolini scrittore l'account
psicanalista in quegli anni che non
sicuro che non si non si conoscevano
personalmente e non
si leggevano se non occasionalmente ci
sono delle somiglianze delle convergenze
e questo discorso confluisce inun in un
in alcuni elementi comuni che cosa
accoglie la mutazione antropologica
la mutazione antropologica coglie
secondo me molto bene quel processo quel
divenire liquido della società quel
processo di allentamento dei legami che
dà forma al nostro presente e lo
distingue dalla società super e gotica
fondata sull'idea di dovere sacrificio
da cui provenivano i nostri nonni
queste allentamento dei legami agisce
fondamentalmente a tre livelli il primo
livello è quello familiare le la
struttura della famiglia tradizionale si
è dissolta oggetto della riflessione
pasoliniana negli scritti corsari sono
le le trasformazioni portate dal
divorzio e dall'aborto pasolini assume
un atteggiamento provocatorio nei
confronti queste trasformazioni
provocatorio contratti reazionari però
coglie la natura epocale di questo
passaggio quanto la risoluzione della
famiglia tradizionale significhi in una
prospettiva di media e di lunga durata
il secondo elemento è la dissoluzione
dei legami intrapsichici quelli che
tengono insieme gli individui oggi
rispetto a la società che pasolini
descriveva in rubrica va come clerico
fascista
noi siamo abituati ad accettare come
normale e come
ovvia una forma di blanda schizofrenia
di lacerazione del nostro io che ancora
per pasolini era un problema e per le
generazioni precedenti e quella di
pasolini era davvero una questione su
cui riflettere la letteratura da questo
punto di vista ci dà degli esempi
straordinari e difficili da trovare in
altri settori della conoscenza se la
letteratura non ne avesse lasciato
traccia
il tema della lacerazione dell'io entra
nel romanzo europeo e occidentale della
seconda metà dell'ottocento soprattutto
grazie rientra grazie a molti autori
però l'autore che è veramente cardine in
nella descrizione di questo processo ed
aste yevski molto spesso i personaggi da
scaglia rischiano i personaggi d'asta
rischiano i principali agiscono mossi da
impulsi che non controllano in tre
romanzi da stajerske ricorre più o meno
la stessa espressione detta dai
personaggi principali po fatto questo e
non so perché personaggi agiscono come
se il loro io si lacera se è la loro
vita psichica venisse attraversata da
delle forze straniere che è stato detto
è uno dei primi scrittori che veramente
introduce l'inconscio come forza attiva
nell'ambito della letteratura però per
dosto yevski per i personaggi sono stati
chiari la scissione un problema è un
enorme problema morale tanto è vero che
ci si deve riflettere moralmente
filosoficamente per scrittori per gli
scrittori contemporanei nocita t2 la
lista potrebbe essere molto lunga cito
questi due perché sono particolarmente
significativi
bret easton ellis roberto bolano bret
easton ellis nato nel 1964 vivente
americano roberto bolano cileno nato nel
1953 è morto nel 2003 uno dei maggiori
scrittori a cavallo fra gli anni 90 e
gli anni zero del xxi secolo la
scissione dei personaggi tutti i loro
personaggi sono scissi la sezione dei
personaggi è un dato ovvio
non si spiega i personaggi agiscono non
sanno perché è spesso agiscono contro il
loro impulso iniziale e questo è uno
stato di cose accettato dunque
lacerazione del allentamento dei legami
familiari allentamento dei legami
intrapsichici il terzo elemento su cui
potremo riflettere è più ampio
l'allentamento dei legami sociali come
oggi è stato detto parlando al tema
della tribalizzazione una caratteristica
delle società ultracontemporanea
l'allentamento della coesione sociale
la società sì sì sì tribalità e si
balcanizza nell'ambito della storia
politica un un effetto di questa
balcanizzazione tribalizzazione per
esempio la crisi dei partiti la perenne
crisi nelle aggregazioni collettive che
si riflette nella crisi dei partiti
politici
c'è però un livello più profondo e più
interessante di questa crisi dei legami
sociali e per illustrarlo ricordiamo ad
un altro scrittore raymond carver uno
dei maggiori scrittori di racconti della
seconda metà del novecento americano
nato nel 1938 morto nel 1988 autore di
racconti davvero notevolissimi uno dei
più belli
si intitola in inglese so much so close
to home
tradotto con tutta quell'acqua due passi
da casa racconta la storia di stuart
steward è un brav'uomo un padre di
famiglia lavoratore lavora tutta la
settimana tutti i mesi quando ha tempo
libero accompagna il figlio a giocare a
baseball
ogni tanto si ritaglia un fine settimana
per sé e questo fine settimana per sé lo
trascorre con gli amici e va a pescare
un giorno andando a pescare
comincia il fine settimana comincia in
questo caso il sabato stewart e gli
amici arrivano al fiume e vedono
galleggiare nel fiume il corpo nudo di
una ragazza morta
lo assicurano ad un albero e continuano
a pescare continuano a pescare tutto il
sabato pomeriggio tutta la domenica poi
ripartono e solo la domenica sera quando
hanno finito di pescare danno l'allarme
avvertono lo sceriffo quando crea la
moglie di stuart viene a sapere di
quello che ti porti gli amici hanno
fatto rimane trasecolata mi sembra un
atto spaventoso e chiede a stewart come
come come hai fatto a fare una cosa
simile estiva non capisce dice tanto non
c'era nulla da fare la morta crea
riflette è il personaggio che che tiene
le fila del racconto riflette dice ormai
si è arrivati a un punto in cui due cose
sono certe 1 agli altri non frega più
nulla delle altre persone e due nulla ha
veramente importanza ormai claire
riflette sulla polverizzazione del
legami sociali elementari cioè su un
mondo in cui è possibile venire meno ad
in modo assolutamente naturale ea farlo
non è un mostro è un uomo perbene venire
meno ad alcuni fondamentali della
civiltà seppellire i morti rispettare la
vita umana e avvertire le autorità in
presenza di un crimine questo
allentamento dei legami sociali e che
carver rappresenta attraverso questo
racconto è un una caratteristica delle
nostre società
che giudizio dà re ha di fronte a questi
fenomeni
il giudizio ovviamente spetta a ciascun
ea ciascuno
una delle caratteristiche della
modernità è il suo costitutivo
relativismo è molto difficile
o meglio si può argomentare sulle
questioni etico politiche si arriva però
un punto in cui la decisione sui valori
è individuale
la cosa però che si può dire che la
modernità è fondamentalmente ambivalenza
noi abbiamo guadagnato molte cose ed io
personalmente non vorrei mai tornare
indietro e non rimpiango la societa di
primo novecento e tuttavia questa
conquista lascia un residuo un fondo
delle esigenze che sono frustrate delle
dei valori che sono calpestati dei
rimpianti la letteratura lavora su
questo lato la letteratura è spesso
molto spesso il lato oscuro della vita
sociale o come diceva un grande critico
letterario della seconda metà del
novecento la letteratura è il ritorno
del re presso grazie
[Applauso]